so was on a Google hangout this morning
with Jamie who's my media coach and she
tells me and then how come you don't
share any more stories from your
childhood I want to see those stories
and have a teachable lesson on top of
them so Jamie this video today is for
you when I was growing up in grade 2
grade 3 grade 4 I used to have a lot of
nervous tics some of them were really
embarrassing I used to blink alot
constantly I used to do this with my
neck and then have to adjust with my
shoulder when I was walking I used to
always have to step on the lines or
completely avoid the lines on the
sidewalk one of the most embarrassing
one was I used to always try to kick my
own butt where I would always have the
I'd have to push my leg out and I
wouldn't be happy until the heel hit my
butt and I have to do that a couple
times before I can move on with the rest
of my day I was also getting into a lot
of fights at my school so seeing this my
parents are really worried and it took
me to go see a child psychologist I
didn't know she was a psychologist my
parents said I was gonna go play games
with somebody and we had some games
together and she showed me these ink
blots and told me what are you seeing
these pictures and she asked me a bunch
of questions the immediate
recommendation was that I switched
schools right away and so in grade 5 I
transferred to a new school called
Crescent and ended up staying there from
grade five all the way to graduating
high school and the ticks got better for
the most part they went away completely
to this day I still have a few minor
ones where if I'm thinking or if I'm
stressed or if I'm tired you could see
my ears move but other than that they're
gone what it really made me think about
was the importance of your environment
so your environment is either something
that builds you up that that lifts your
spirits that helps you go chase your
dreams or something that squashes you
down that makes you shrink that makes
you accept a lesser life so think about
the people that you surround yourself
with think about the the TV shows you're
watching and the media that you're
consuming and the place that you go to
work does your environment build you up
or squash you down changing my
environment had a dramatic impact on the
quality of my life and the contribution
to my success as an entrepreneur and
changing yours can have the same impact
for you
belief if you like this video you want
to see more subscribe to the channel
thank you guys for watching I'll see you
soon
daddy I hoped you enjoyed the story let
me know every week I share inspiring and
motivational stories that really mean
something to me that I hope you'll check
out in my newsletter below
you